the company started 99 as a web design
company actually and we were doing
client work for hire you know redesign
people's sites and we started getting
really busy in about 2,000 let's see
2002 2003 well needed a better way to
manage our client projects and so
because we were shooting things back and
forth via email which is what people
typically do and we said you know we
looked around some software that existed
we weren't really happy with what we
what we saw so we decided to build our
own product internally to use with our
clients to share designs and ideas
online with people and it worked out
pretty well and we said you know hey
maybe there's a business here maybe we
can you know if we need this thing
someone else needs it and that was kind
of that's sort of the thing that
37signals is all about that we build
stuff for ourselves and we recognize
that if we need it other people probably
need it too and so since then we've
launched six different products who
wrote a book and we've done a variety of
other things all based on the things
that we need or we want for ourselves
realizing that we're not special other
people would like it to
a virtual company and a physical company
so we're 20 people half in Chicago and
then half elsewhere and ten other cities
around the world so we're a little bit
of a mix of the traditional and the sort
of next generation new wave virtual sort
of company our general feeling though is
that it's best if people stay away from
each other as much as possible because
when people are all together all the
time it's really easy to interrupt each
other and we found that that's kind of
biggest problem with the traditional
workplace is interruption so we're
trying to avoid that at all costs
well it kind of happened because
originally my partner in the business I
got named David Hanson hand Meyer Hanson
actually it's his full name um he was
working in Denmark now I was working in
Chicago and we got a lot of stuff done
working together to seven time zones
apart and then eventually he moved to
Chicago and were like man he's in
Chicago this is going to be great or get
more work done together and he comes to
Chicago we get less work done together
and we start to realize it because we're
both in the same physical place in the
same physical office were just
interrupting each other all the time by
talking and there's something good about
talking and FaceTime you know but too
much of it is a bad thing so we decided
that we're going to kind of try and
simulate the old way of working which
was he was in Denmark and I was in
Chicago so we wouldn't see each other
very often so he worked at home and I
worked at home and if we came into the
office we came in and off times often
and we found out that we started getting
more work done again when we were split
up and so we sort of carried that
through throughout the business now that
you know we try and stay away from each
other as much as we can we have a
physical office we just built a new
office and I can talk about that a
little bit because we try to take this
philosophy and build it into a physical
space the most of the time we don't talk
to each other we communicate over the
web using our products or email or
variety of other tools you can use and
then when you do that someone can hide
the thing when they don't want to be
bothered but you can't stop someone from
like calling your name across the room
or pulling you into a meeting or
something like that that's hard to stop
but if you communicate virtually through
you know base camp or instant messaging
or email it's easy for you to hide that
and then get back to it later when
you're free so then you decide when you
want to be in communication with
somebody else and let it instead of
someone else deciding what they want you
to talk to them